en troisième position et téléspectateurs
ont choisi avec 33% des voix
il fait bien il le fait bien
rachid arhab
matthieu delormeau
non
à ses côtés les garçons confondus en
fait ces trois garçons k-way et sachez
que ces trois garçons nous on était
rouge et non oui mais non baptisé nokia
cegid pas remarqué plus d'hétéros mais
pas nicolas pernikoff qu'on est d'accord
cas ce que je voulais dire en fait
d'accord d'accord tout cas merci bravo
matthew barrie match est bon ces braves
hommes avec 36 % de votes non la
médaille d'argent le chroniqueur numéro
deux préférés des français
et
sera mikko dans cet été il sera à cannes
dans le jacuzzi à sera l'économie
heureux merci beaucoup bravo aux équipes
non c'est grâce à toi cyril je t'aime
très fort habitent ensemble et qu'on ait
un enfant très bien tout d'abord
habitent ensemble et puis je vais guérir
mon anus et puis on boit
on va voir l'avenir beaucoup plus clair
d'accord je guéris tout sourire sera pas
une case inquiet non plus mais je suis
déçu c'est un prompt rétablissement
[Rires]
j'espère que le gagnant nous freine dans
ce hameau swing
je ne sais pas quel gagnant c'est
quelqu'un la danse de la victoire mais
bien eu que des révélations non les
révélations professionnels les
révélations capillaires les révélations
corporelle sentiments et des révélations
amoureuse sentimentale et des
révélations sexuelle moche incroyable à
quelle année il aurait pu rentrer par
ont été patientes a pas vu ce retard à
jouer là-dedans
entre la banane et l'abricot son coeur
vacille
[Rires]
il a deux passions dans la vie
la télévision et nico et salade de
fruits mais les isidro classe
malheureusement
il n'ya pas l'abonnement à free
c'est quelqu'un qui aime beaucoup
les aires d'autoroutes gens à les aires
d'autoroute c'est quelqu'un que je
connais depuis des années
c'est quelqu'un qui
est un ami il le sait
je ne croyais pas qu'il arriverait aussi
ou en partant d'aussi bas
et pourtant il y est arrivé non mais
c'est vrai
c'est un petit peu l'homme à tout faire
de cette émission livreur le jour
ou ironiques heures l'après-midi
danseurs line
dance et
danseurs auront beau mykonos
avec 50 2%
le chroniqueur préféré des français trop
émue et le jura bertrand deckers
rockeur préféré des français
est celui qui s'appelle andré cyril que
j'ai rebaptisé raymond parce que je lui
ai dit ne peut pas avoir mieux si reed
dans la même équipe ah ouais alors
c'était au moins changer de nom ouais
bah des premières
dames ans je vais demander de fermer sa
gueule
et de s'appeler par un autre nom qu'est
ce qui m'a fait hésiter mais pas le
niveau de notoriété c'est moi mais c'est
peut-être plus chiant pour moi de
changer c'est logique ban a eu lieu à
pas s'appeler richarde maintenant
demandent à dire oui n'oubliez pas les
paroles présenté par bell chara
voilà tu prends pas m'appeler
sur la non firmann ferment
le chroniqueur préféré des français vous
avez voté vous étiez plus de 50 milles
il remercie d'ailleurs damien mercereau
mon ami de tv mag qui est à l'origine ce
sondage
c'est vraiment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
oui
pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chaque match on s'est parlé pendant la
danse et regarde y'a pas de danse hétéro
[Rires]
ton corps pas de toi même mais c'est
vrai c'est génial
[Applaudissements]
bah écoute c'est bien parce que tu as eu
beaucoup de succès cette année
est-ce que tu as quelque chose à dire
non merci des gens cesser les gens en
fait c'est fou mais c'est ce que j'ai
dit je le rappelle j'aurais pas que les
manifs et noah discours
regardé l'émission ça regardait depuis
tu le sais je la regardais j'étais fan
de cette émission tu as regardé ou
amicaux doute la regarder j'ai regardé
sur france 4 quand je suis venu j'ai dit
je vais rester deux jours trois jours
avec vous et hélas les gens ils disent
que je suis le chroniqueur préféré donc
pas faire discours mais merci des
gencives ou fait dans
le plus grand silence
non mais sans y apporter beaucoup
d'amour voilà non mais dis donc t'es où
quelques chaussures je suis heureuse
j'aurai pris ma raconte moi
qui fait
que je vais y aller
[Rires]
[Musique]
bon tu as été élu ce soir
chroniqueurs préférés des français je
vais demander aux autres de les serrer
mon seul petit moulin mais non même
si c'est vraiment vraiment l armée c
derrière les autres sont moment derrière
les sommes peuvent sembler très bien
entendu merci voilà sa mort est hilare
garcia n'ont vraiment mon chéri
tu es aujourd'hui et non là franchement
ça me fait non mais ça me fait quelque
chose à moi aussi parce que c'est un
pari raymond la base raymond à la base
c'était mon pari et quand je l'appelais
il m'a dit qu'est ce que je viens faire
là
et je le dis pour l'instant
il a livré quelques fruits
très vite trouvé sa place dans
l'émission je vais demander qu'une seule
chose soit le raymond que je connais
dans la vie si tu es alors vraiment que
le connaît dans la vie tu seras le rémo
exceptionnel qu'on voit aujourd'hui à
l'écran
[Musique]
est mon
aujourd'hui c'est un grand jour pour toi
pour ta famille
je regarde ce qui est dit je regarde
qu'elle raymond hains
aujourd'hui c'est
il ya eu des tournants dans ta nou
le premier c'est ce soir je sais que tu
vas nullité vacances au camping des
flots bleus
[Rires]
laura - 2 g dans l'eau mais
t'inquiète pas ça se passera bien
et puis
il ya eu cette consécration je vais le
chroniqueur d'année avec 52% des voix
raymond ce mois
là sans rire où je crois que tu es très
émue et tu le mérites pour moi je
voulais te dire je suis très très fier
de toi parce que tu as fait une année
formidable
et tu sais que je t'ai jamais lâcher
parce que on a eu des petits on peut
sans briller mais comme on s'embrouille
dans la vie et c'est vrai qu'il ya plein
de gens qui m'ont dit oui parfois et on
s'embrouille avec raymond mais quand on
s'embrouille avec raymond c'est comme on
se bat on s'embrouille avec un pote on
n'en parle même pas le
la fin des missions et raymond il ya un
truc qui lui fait de la peine je vous
dis qui me touche beaucoup c'est que il
s'en fout quand on dit du mal de lui sur
les réseaux mais quand on dit du mal de
moi et là qu'une envie c'est de courir
nu à mykonos
aboutir il a raison ça c'est vrai et ça
ça m'a fait mouche et voilà qu'on dira
que de six heures si les gens bien et
bravo à tous parce que on nous ferons
faire ensemble en fait l'émission laffan
semble je peux pas tout seul chez rien
tout seul je parle pas en premier c'est
d'abord les autres qui prennent des
risques
et voilà c'est pas de mots c'est c'est
bien c'est celle là c'est des [ __ ]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
avec moi les procès mais un accord de
match et d'amour
[Applaudissements]